hot breath how do you find because i
like
a lot of people do try to do edgier
dirtier material
and you mentioned how sometimes you get
too many groans you have to dial it back
how do you find that sweet spot that
still makes like a
dirty joke still like palatable
um well i always say say everything with
a smile
you'll get away with
um you'll get away with murder if you're
charming or with a positive attitude i
think
just think of like isn't it crazy
sometimes you could do it
two different people can do almost the
same kind of material but one is seen as
dirtier than the other
and i think a lot of the times it it is
on the delivery
or the your demeanor on stage or maybe
how you're dressed
or i mean there's so many factors but i
feel like
um yeah it's it's just like i think it
just depends on like
how you say it um but
i don't want to gross out anybody but
you can actually work with a grown
sometimes if you get a grown it causes
tension and then you can figure out a
line to release that tension with the
groan and then that
can make the the groan worth it
huh
you know sometimes like a crowd is like
oh and then
sometimes that feeling you're like well
i don't want them
i feel like i hit a nerve with them and
then you can take that
um tension and then you can use it to
your advantage
and either have equipped to come off of
that
or not oh right and react to the groan
almost have a tag off of the groan
yeah it's a good it's a way to like you
know
turn the room around sometimes you could
make feels like you're about to lose
them
with a bit and you get a groan and i
feel like if you have that happen
you should kind of fig and you want to
still push through that bit you should
figure out a way to use that ground to
your advantage
and figure out a thing to say after that
to deflate the moment
and then get back into the bid again or
something but
it's a great way to get one extra laugh
i think so you shouldn't really be that
afraid of a groan you just don't want to
i don't like some people are like a
grown is just as good as a laugh and i
i'm like no it's not it doesn't feel as
good to me
yeah i i like oh it's a reaction though
so they're not
texting or tweeting so they're still
listening and invested
but yeah yes yeah but so
like that is true so if you have them
listening
just try to deflate it and that'll be a
great way to get an extra laugh or
you'll keep going go down another
tangent or something
oh that is gold hot breath